liebe Freunde des gepflegten
Animationsfilms er kommt zu uns der
Meister des Animationsfilms des 3D
animierten Films John Lassiter aus
seiner Feder stammen z.B Toy Story das
große Krabbeln Cars und jetzt kommt er
ins Kino mit Cars 2 und da seht ihr mal
wie das bei uns ist der Film startte
nämlich in Deutschland am 28 Juli nach
dem jetzigen Plan das heißt von diesem
Video bis zum Interview mit ihm dann
wird zwei Monate dauern also es kann
immer ein bisschen dauern und noch eine
Kleinigkeit auf Facebook in der
Fangruppe von klicksom da könnt er mit
entscheiden wer einer der nächsten Gäste
bei klickum wird inzwischen schon 10 000
Stimmen abgegeben der Hammer so und
jetzt noch mal zur videofrage
genau soll nämlich eine videofrage sein
eine videofrage im Chor eine videofrage
am besten ansonsten seid kreativ lest
den Infotext und dann kann eigentlich
nichts mehr schiefgehen